today I'm cosplaying as yellow starburst
the thing that no one wants on brand
know how many some people don't know now
you know your life it's different now I
am going to warn you that this video is
going to be probably frustrating I don't
watch many things other than terrible
reality television my sanity slip away
that's it so I asked you guys to send me
your favorite shows that you're watching
and surprise surprise I haven't seen
most of them so I decided it's a perfect
opportunity to try and guess exactly
what those beloved shows are about with
no watching knowledge then you guys in
the comments get to tell me how close I
got to the actual premise of said show
and is if you stick around long enough
through all the frustration and anger
you will likely have for how completely
perfect I'm going to be at this game I
wrote on a bunch of shows with no cars
and I put them in this let's start
guessing okay member I told you guys are
gonna get frustrated one that I'm gonna
put you your beloved show premise and
two you're gonna be so mad at how many
obviously good shows I believe you that
they're great that I haven't watched so
trigger warning you're gonna get pissed
at me hey mix tip I know I know you
screaming at your computer him exhale is
clearly about a mage that works
primarily on human hands she keeps him
clean she's not a nail technician she's
a hand made full maintenance talking
palm back a palm a little bit onto the
wrist just a little bit that's a
separate entity right there but now it's
the story of her life because she met
someone that has fevered hands and hands
four feet because he played would you
rather with witch doctor and would you
rather have feet for her hands and hands
her feet would you rather have a
Stegosaurus of penises on your back and
he took the first one and so she sees
that he has fever hands and then she
goes oh my god and she tortured she's
not shying away from it but she
definitely it's not in her job
description to keep clean feet but
technically they're his hands it opens
up this whole kind of
question about like just because we call
body part that does it mean it's that if
it's in the place like if I have a foot
in the place where my hand is is that
now at hand or is it still a foot I
don't walk on it what is the definition
of feet and what is the definition of
hand if crisis of identity really is
that the core of this like you'd end up
getting married and ironically enough
the babies have penises all down their
back like a Stegosaurus birth defect so
now it all tells tough happy endings
there's a way to make a penis tale
Stegosaurus happy ending [ __ ] joke
there I'll leave that to you
that was pretty perfect and spot-on so
if you also haven't seen it like me
sorry spoilers okay next bones bones
takes place in an alternate universe
where ours are no longer part of the
English language basically a very
sexually charged show about the owners
but in this alternate universe they're
called bone and they're also you know
like you got bones like money boners are
a form of Commerce in this alternate
universe stimulation in the pelvic
region is the cornerstone of the economy
when the Dow drops it really drops it's
on Showtime fun for the whole family
next you are the worst okay this is
obviously about a high school football
team whose mascot is liverwurst and that
is the lowest rung of totem pole and so
he's always a hunger games
esque type of competition through the
high school of trying to get out of
being the worst just basically The
Hunger Games meets Friday Night Lights
meets liverwurst
you're the worst spot on next killing
Eve it's about someone that read the
Bible and is absolutely in love with Eve
Adam and Eve so they build themselves a
time-traveling device to go back to when
Adam and Eve were around so that he can
kill Eve make her laugh slay her and
when this guy or girl we don't know for
sure goes back in time here's enough to
give Eve a rib to impress I mean he's
from the world of mcribs
is that haven't been Eve got the Bible
he wants his baby back baby back baby
back baby back that's the theme song
okay now today next how to get away with
murder it's about someone that is no
falsely accused of a crime and is being
tracked down by a mafia of sorts and
needs to get into the witness protection
program
but they won't allow the
person into the witness protection
program so now our main character needs
to run away with a group of crows how to
get away with murder perfect next this
is us I know guys I know this is a
cartoon about lovable charming outgoing
breast implants that can talk to people
and every time they meet to my new thing
just go this is us it's too easy next
one no not Erb Winona your ear went on
an ear hurt by Nona Kirk okay this is
about Oh girl named Winona and when she
was born in the hospital they were
writing down on her birth certificate
her mom burped while saying her last
name and so the nurse always wrote down
her but then she since been estranged
from her parents as an adult and now
needs to track down what her real last
name is so she can find out who she
really is
spoiler turns out her real last name is
taint the monster is really to live in
blissful ignorance and be happy with
what you have next Criminal Minds this
is a game show where they pair of
regular people with criminals and the
regular people have to guess what the
criminal is pet peeve is like what do
you mind and if they get right they win
money and if they get it wrong they
switch places with the criminal in the
criminals free and then the regular
person goes to jail for whatever the
offense was that the criminal did high
highs low lows in this game show ya
Legion one of those doctor shows about
just likes terrible skin rashes not for
the faint at heart
next Riverdale this is a docu-series
following the rivals of the Chippendales
dancers is a river dancers who
Riverdance very sexy they're starting
their own franchise
Riverdale the finale episode where they
have a dance-off Riverdale doesn't move
their arms too much Chippendale so move
their legs too much where do they come
together on the groin section it is
steaming next American Horror Story
oh this was the original title Fox News
lalala shits Creek this is basically
Austin's Creek Dawson went on a huge
tirade and just like Shh holy [ __ ] in
his own creek I started to move
so then the shit's fought Dawson's old
house it's like the story of them having
to clean up the creek like that show
Gold Rush where that the mine for gold
except they gotta get out of the creek
if they had awesome [ __ ] out of this
Creek Wow okay I mean let me know in the
comments down below but I think I'd
known all of those sorry that I'm so
unrelated Lee great at this game and
also sorry if that was so painful
congratulations have you made it this
far in the video without completely
clicking off out of pure pure angst
towards me I get it if you guys liked
this kind of video give it a thumbs up
and hit that Bell notification so you
know when I upload videos because you
said I'm fully living up to my
consistently inconsistent tagline here
other than that I don't know also
remember no jewelry
cat and cat owner jewelry is available
link in description box below go check
that out before it's all sold out